attorney general Jeff session says any
suggestion that he conspired with
Russians during the campaign is a quote
appalling and detestable lie the Senate
Intelligence Committee question sessions
at a nearly three hour hearing yesterday
and he defended his role in the firing
of FBI director James Comey Nancy Cordes
is on Capitol Hill with that part of the
story Nancy good morning good morning
Republicans say it is now time to get
back to this investigations original
focus which was Russian meddling in the
2016 election Democrats say that's hard
to do when the president won't
acknowledge Russian meddling and when
his top advisors like sessions won't
answer all their questions I mean what
is this an angry Attorney General said
he was being smeared by rumors that he
had undisclosed contact with Russian
officials they are none senator Wyden
there are none sessions argued there was
nothing wrong with his involvement in
Jim Comey's firing even though he had
recused himself from the Russia
investigation Comey headed the recusal
involved one case involved in the
Department of Justice ah and in the FBI
they conduct thousands of investigations
but he refused to describe the
conversations he had with the President
on the matter mr. chairman I'm not able
to comment I'm not able to comment on
their and any other matter you're not
answering questions you're impeding this
investigation it would be inappropriate
for me to answer and reveal private
conversations with the president it left
one Democrat suggesting that perhaps
sessions should be held in contempt of
Congress we may have to litigate that if
we think they're not making a sound
basis for their claim Republicans argued
sessions was following a long-standing
tradition there isn't a president in the
history the United States that has not
had that expectation unless those
conversations are about wrongdoing of
which there is no evidence senators from
both sides did ask sessions about the
president's repeated one-on-one
communications with the former FBI
director there's nothing wrong with the
president having a communication with
the FBI director but it did appear that
mr. Comey felt that that conversation
wasn't proper he was concerned about it
there have been reports of tension
between President Trump and his Attorney
General but a White House spokesperson
says that the president thinks sessions
did a very good job yesterday and that
he made a strong case that there was no
collusion charlie between the Trump
campaign and the Russians thanks Nancy